Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. The Battle of Cable Street has a deep personal significance to me as I learned all about this historic event on the 4th of October 1936 from my mother who was there herself. 84 years ago she stood alongside many others and later recalled how tens of thousands of people from an incredibly diverse range of community organisations,
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。卡布尔街之战（Battle of Cable Street）对我个人有着深远的意义，因为我是在1936年10月4日从我母亲那里了解到这一历史事件的，她当时就在现场。84年前，她与许多人并肩站在一起，后来她回忆起成千上万来自各种极其多元的社区组织的人们，
faith groups, trade unions, the Labour Party, left-wing groups and others had come together against the planned march by Oswald Mosley's Union of British Fascists and those police guarding it through a heavily Jewish neighbourhood. Communities joined together to support each other with one simple aim, to stop the fascists from marching through the East End and determinedly say they wouldn't let them pass. Those who stood there in Cable Street all those years ago did so as an act of defiance and an act of principle. And we walk in their shadow. That, Dominic, was Jeremy Corbyn, the late leader of the Labour Party, writing in the Morning Star on the 1st of October 2020 about one of the mythic episodes in the
宗教团体、工会、工党、左翼团体和其他组织，是如何团结起来反对奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利（Oswald Mosley）领导的英国法西斯联盟（Union of British Fascists）计划中的游行，以及那些保护游行队伍穿过犹太人聚居区的警察。社区团结一致，互相支持，目标只有一个：阻止法西斯分子穿过东区（East End），并坚定地表示绝不让他们通过。那些多年前站在卡布尔街的人，是以反抗和原则的名义这样做的。我们正走在他们的阴影之下。多米尼克，那是杰里米·科尔宾（Jeremy Corbyn），已故工党领袖，于2020年10月1日在《晨星报》（Morning Star）上写下的关于工党历史上、反法西斯历史上最具神话色彩的事件之一，也就是后来被称为卡布尔街之战的事件。正如杰里米·科尔宾所言，左翼团体和其他人团结起来，反对奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利的英国法西斯联盟计划中穿过东区的游行。我相信你会告诉我，这是一个被高度神话化的事件。好吧，我有什么资格反驳呢？毕竟那是杰里米·科尔宾。因为如果一个著名的事件
history of the Labour Party, in the history of anti-fascism, what's come to be called the Battle of Cable Street, when, as Jeremy Corbyn put it, left-wing groups and others came together against the planned march by Oswald Moses' Union of British Fascists through the East End. I'm sure you're going to tell me that this is a hugely mythologized event. Well, who am I to argue? It's Jeremy Corbyn. Because it wouldn't really be an episode of the rest of history if a famous episode
最终没有被神话，那就不算是《历史的余味》的一集了。但这是我们关于英国法西斯主义系列节目的第三集，讲述的是20世纪20年代和30年代英国法西斯主义的历史。在第二集结束时，我们看到奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利的处境相当糟糕。我的意思是，他有一个相当壮观的开局。他曾填满了肯辛顿的奥林匹亚体育场（Olympia Stadium），但那里发生了许多暴力事件，人们开始撤回对他的支持。看起来英国法西斯联盟似乎正在走向衰落。它刚出现似乎就要消失了。那么接下来发生了什么？在这之间，接下来发生了什么？我们是如何走到卡布尔街之战的？发生了什么？请告诉我们。好吧，首先，大家好。汤姆，我想问你，你是否
doesn't turn out to be mythologized. But this is the third episode of our series on British fascism, history of British fascism in the 20s and 30s. And we left Oswald Mosley at the end of episode two pretty down on his luck. I mean, he'd had a kind of spectacular start. He'd been filling out Olympia Stadium in Kensington, but lots of violence there and people start to withdraw their support. And it looks as though the British Union of Fascists is going into a decline. It's no sooner arrived than it seems to be departing. So what happens next? Between that, what happens next? How do we get to Cable Street? What's going on? Fill us in. Well, first of all, hello, everybody. And I will say, Tom, I wondered whether you would
从杰里米·科尔宾的那段引语中得到了很好的印象，因为杰里米·科尔宾是一个很难模仿的人。你觉得怎么样？但我认为非常好。你捕捉到了杰里米·科尔宾声音中轻微的鼻音，但你还捕捉到了一个不寻常的技巧，就是在句子中间随机大声喊出某些词。是的，是的。这是一种枯燥的列表式表达。然后他会突然大喊。这正是我想要传达的。所以我很高兴你注意到了这一点。我觉得做得非常漂亮。如果他正在听，我不知道他是否是《历史的余味》俱乐部的成员。
get a good impression out of that Jeremy Corbyn quotation, because Jeremy Corbyn is a hard man to do. What do you think of it? But I thought it was very good. And what you captured, there is a slight nasal quality to Jeremy Corbyn's voice, but also what you captured is an unusual trick of shouting at random words in the middle of a sentence. Yes, yes. It's kind of a kind of dreary expanse of lists. Then he'll suddenly shout. That's very much what I wanted to convey. So I'm glad you picked up on that. I thought it was beautifully done. And if he is listening, I don't know if he is a member of the Restors History Club.
不知何故，我会感到相当惊讶。但如果他在听，他应该联系我们，让我们知道他有多喜欢这个节目。所以，是的，上次我们以奥林匹亚会议结束，在帝国肯辛顿的大角厅（Great Corner Hall）发生了暴力事件，成千上万的人，包括100多名议员，惊恐地看着黑衫军纠察队员殴打抗议者和示威者，当然，当我们谈到卡布尔街和东区的事件时，会有更多关于示威者的内容。但正如你所说，汤姆，法西斯运动在1934年和1935年非常颓废。他们失去了很多支持。为什么？部分是因为暴力，部分是因为媒体撤回了对他们的支持。但我认为还有更重要的事情，那就是莫斯利建立英国法西斯联盟是因为他认为英国
Somehow I'd be quite surprised. But if he he is listening he should get in touch and let us know how much he's enjoyed it so yes we ended last time with the olympia meeting the violence of the imperial kensington at the great corner hall there thousands of people including more than 100 mps who watched many of them in horror as black shirt stewards beat up hecklers and demonstrators of course more onto demonstrators when we get to Cable Street and the events in the East End. But as you say, Tom, the fascist movement, it's very moribund in 1934 and 1935. They've lost a lot of support. Why? Partly because of the violence and partly because the press have withdrawn their backing. But also, I think there's something bigger, which is that Moseley had set up the British Union of Fascists because he thought that British
资本主义、英国民主正走向大崩溃，正如他当时所说的那样，人们会想要一个替代方案。但实际上，他完全错了。我认为我们了解20世纪20年代和30年代的故事。这就是为什么英国法西斯主义是了解这一点的绝佳窗口。我认为我们对英国20世纪20年代和30年代的故事理解有误，因为坦率地说，我们有点太美国化了。所以我们认为20世纪20年代是鸡尾酒杯和快车，而30年代是戴着布帽、非常悲惨的男人。在某些方面，实际上恰恰相反。
capitalism, British democracy was heading for a great smash, as he would have said at the time, and the people will want an alternative. And actually, he is quite wrong. We get the story, I think, of the 20s and 30s. And this is one reason why British fascism is a really great window into this. I think we get the story of the 20s and 30s wrong in Britain, because frankly, we're a bit too Americanized. So we think of the 20s as kind of cocktail glasses and fast cars, and the 30s as men in cloth caps, very miserable. In some ways, it's actually the other way around.
20世纪20年代是一个非常冲突、困难的时期，它是英国大罢工的十年，失业率非常高。在30年代，英国当然受到了大萧条的影响，但它受到的影响几乎比任何其他可比的西方国家都要小。我想是因为贾罗游行（Jarrow March），对吧？我的意思是，它显得如此生动。所以那是失业者从北方一直游行到伦敦。是的。还有爱德华八世（Edward VIII）在成为国王后前往威尔士，会见那里的煤矿工人并说必须做点什么。所以我们从那两个著名的事件中得到的印象是，整个英国都陷入了失业之中，因为那是忘记了
The 20s is a really conflicted, difficult, it's the decade of the general strike in Britain, very high unemployment. In the 30s, Britain, of course, it's affected by the Great Depression, but it's not as affected as almost any other comparable Western country. I think it's because of the Jarrow March, isn't it? I mean, it looms so vividly. So that's the March of the Unemployed from the North all the way down to London. Yes. And also Edward VIII as he becomes going to Wales and meeting the coal miners there and saying something must be done. And so the sense we have from those two famous episodes that the whole of Britain is admired in unemployment, because that's to forget
大规模的住房繁荣，所有那些工业发展，沿着道路开始建造的带状开发项目。英国在30年代末实际上处于繁荣状态，我的意思是，在繁荣的心脏地带，即使你在工业区面临大规模失业。确实如此。这就像我2000年代在谢菲尔德大学（University of Sheffield）讲课时讲的内容。
the massive housing boom, all those kind of industrial developments, kind of ribbon developments along the roads that are starting to be built. Britain is actually kind of booming in the late 30s, I mean, in the kind of the prosperous heartlands, even as you're getting mass unemployment in the industrial regions. It is. This is like the lecture that I used to give at the University of Sheffield in the 2000s.
这对我来说简直是天籁之音，因为剧作家、小说《罪恶之家》（An Inspector Calls）的作者J.B.普里斯特利（J.B. Priestley），是20世纪30年代和40年代英国伟大的社会评论家。他写了一本书叫《英国之旅》（English Journey），我想大约是在1936年或37年左右。他说有三个英国。一个是茶巾、国民信托基金（National Trust）的房子、软糖、科茨沃尔德村庄（Cotswold Villages）的英国。
This is music to my ears, because J.B. Priestley, the playwright, author of In a Spectre Calls, but a great kind of social commentator in 1930s, 1940s Britain. He wrote a book called English Journey, I think about 1936, 37 or so. And he said there are three Englands. There is the England of the kind of tea towel, you know, the National Trust House, fudge, Cotswold Villages.
唐顿庄园（Downton Abbey）。是的，有那个英国。他说还有北方工业城市的英国。所以人们穿着木屐，鹅卵石街道，到处是煤烟，矿工。那个英国显然在大萧条中遭受了巨大的痛苦。但他表示还有第三个英国，那就是人们在新建的装饰艺术风格游泳池里游泳、购买收音机、正如你所说，生活在斯坦利·鲍德温（Stanley Baldwin）的英国，生活在所有这些沿着主干道建造的带状开发项目中的人们，红砖半独立式建筑。因为直到今天，英国城市大片地区的建筑环境都可以追溯到30年代。
Downton Abbey. Yeah, there's that England. He said there is the England of the industrial cities of the North. So people wearing clogs, cobbled streets, coal smoke everywhere, miners. That England is obviously really suffering in the depression. But he said there's a third England, which is the England of people going swimming in newly built art deco swimming pools, people buying radios, people living in, as you said, in Stanley Baldwin's Britain, in all these ribbon developments along main roads, red brick, semi-detached buildings. Because to this day, the built-up environment of vast swathes of British cities dates from the 30s.
确实如此，完全正确。对于那些人来说，我的意思是，这些人往往比以往任何时候都过得更好。所以这些人是在1931年全国政府（National Government）的巨大压倒性胜利中投票的人。同样，在1935年，他们是那些在无线电上听斯坦利·鲍德温讲话的人，他们说，哦，鲍德温先生是一个非常稳重的人，诸如此类。20世纪30年代的英国资本主义和英国民主中存在一种韧性，这经常被所有关于德国马克思主义者的东西所忽略。与此同时，在德国，各种可怕的事情正在发生。这不仅仅是德国政治和经济轨迹的差异
It does exactly. It does exactly right. And for those people, I mean, often those people are better off than they've ever been. So those are the people who are voting for the national government in the 1931 colossal landslide. And again, in 1935, they are the people who listen to Stanley Baldwin on the wireless and they say, oh, Mr. Baldwin's a very solid chap, all this sort of thing. There was a resilience there to British capitalism and British democracy in the 1930s that is so often missed by all the stuff about the German Marxists. And meanwhile, in Germany, all kinds of terrible things are happening. It's not just that there's a difference in the political and economic arc of Germany
和英国的差异，而且存在某种根本性的文化差异。是的。法西斯主义是外来的、非英国的，而且存在某种根本性的文化差异。是的。法西斯主义是外来的、非英国的，不是那种可以在斯坦利·鲍德温统治的国家扎根的东西。是的，我认为这绝对正确。我认为人们正在观察德国发生的事情。我们在上一集中提到了长刀之夜（Knights of the Long Knives），它发生在奥林匹亚暴力事件三周后。
and Britain, but that there is some sense of a kind of fundamental cultural difference. Yeah. That fascism is alien, un-British, and Britain, but that there is some sense of a kind of fundamental cultural difference. Yeah. That fascism is alien, un-British, not the kind of thing that could put down root in a country governed by Stanley Baldwin. Yeah, I think that's absolutely right. I think people are looking at what's happening in Germany. We mentioned the Knights of the Long Knives in the last episode, which takes place, what is it, three weeks after the violence at Olympia.
人们说，天哪，这是我们在英国最不希望看到的事情，这显然对奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利来说是一个真正的问题。他做了什么？首先，他以有趣的方式行动。他一直是一个凯恩斯主义者。反对自由放任。是的，反对自由放任。现在他变得更加激进地反对资本主义。在1935年左右，BUF，即英国法西斯联盟，他的政党更加激进地谴责资本主义和工业、工业巨头、大企业等等，发挥他们更社会主义的元素。人们说这基本上是我们的
And people say, gosh, that's the last thing we want in Britain, which obviously is a real problem for Oswald Mosley. What does he do? First of all, he moves in interesting ways. He's always been a Keynesian. Anti-lese fair. Yeah, anti-lese fair. Now he becomes much more aggressively anti-capitalist. In 1935 or so, the BUF, the British Union of Fascists, his party are much more aggressively denouncing capitalism and industry, industrial magnates, big business, and so on, playing up their kind of more socialist elements. People saying this is basically our
政党是爱国社会主义，所有这些东西，为保护主义、为将英国与世界经济隔绝、关税壁垒提出了非常有力的论据，实际上其中一些元素后来被20世纪70年代和80年代的工党左翼所采纳。对。所以托尼·本（Tony Benn）是，我的意思是，这基本上就是他在80年代所主张的，不是吗？托尼·本，是的。有一点托尼·本的影子，尽管托尼·本不是法西斯分子，为了避免疑虑。但确实存在那种保护主义元素。我的意思是，你可以追溯到19世纪的约瑟夫·张伯伦（Joseph Chamberlain），一直到托尼·本。然后后来，
party is patriotic socialism, all this kind of thing, making a very strong argument for protectionism, for sealing Britain off from the world economy, tariff walls, actually some of these elements that will be taken up by the Labour left in the 1970s and 1980s. Right. So Tony Benn is, I mean, that's pretty much what he's arguing for in the 80s, isn't it? Tony Benn, yeah. There's a bit of Tony Benn, although Tony Benn's not a fascist, for the avoidance of doubt. But there is that protectionist element. I mean, that you go back to Joseph Chamberlain in the 19th century and forward to Tony Benn. And then later on,
我的意思是，现在工党的最左翼中存在一些元素，他们会说，我们应该在关税壁垒后重建我们的制造业，所有这些东西。但这件事还有另一个层面。莫斯利攻击的事情之一，我们的一些美国听众会知道美国也有类似的运动，就是连锁店。所以他讨厌百货连锁店，玛莎百货（Marks and Spencers）、联合利华（Unilever）、伍尔沃斯（Woolworths）、伯顿（Burtons）裁缝集团。顺便说一句，其中一些是犹太人拥有的。所以我正要问你这个问题。所以大概这就是另一个方面。
I mean, there are elements of the Labour Party on the very left of the Labour Party now who would say, we should rebuild our manufacturing behind a tariff wall and all this sort of stuff. But there's another element to this. One of the things that Mosley attacks, and some of our American listeners will know that there was a similar movement in the United States, is chain stores. So he hates department store chains, Marks and Spencers, Unilever, Woolworths, the Burtons tailoring group. Some of these, by the way, are Jewish owned. So I was going to ask you about that. So presumably that is the other aspect.
所以这有两个要素。一个是，我的意思是，这些是新事物。它们是近几十年来出现的。有很多人感到受到威胁。如果你是一个报刊经销商，如果你是一个小店主，在某个地方有一个小裁缝店，我不知道。索尔兹伯里（Salisbury）。是的，在索尔兹伯里，实际上。索尔兹伯里是一个很好的例子，因为那是连锁店可能会建立并实际上让你倒闭的地方。你会感到愤怒。所以这其中有那个因素。
So there are two elements to this. One is, I mean, these are new things. They've emerged in recent decades. And there are a lot of people who feel threatened by this. If you're a news agent, if you're a small shopkeeper with a little tailor's somewhere in, I don't know. Salisbury. Yeah, in Salisbury, actually. Salisbury is a good example because that's the kind of place where a chain store might set up and actually put you out of business. You will be burning with resentment. So there's that element to it.
所以BUF确实在1934年、35年针对报刊经销商、小店主和出租车司机。但当然，这其中的另一个要素是反犹太主义，因为像玛莎百货这样伟大的英国高街零售商，或者像在利兹成立的蒙塔古·伯顿（Montague Burton）这样的公司，高街裁缝，甚至是斯莱辛格（Slasinger）体育用品，我还没想到斯莱辛格。所以斯莱辛格，斯莱辛格是犹太人拥有的吗？好吧，它是，它是两个来自德国的犹太移民创立的。好吧，你看，完美，我从来没想过这一点，但这是一个完美的例子，所以这让莫斯利开辟了一个新的侧翼，这在法西斯主义中一直存在，但不是他专门的剧目，那就是反犹太主义。
So the BUF are really targeting people like news agents and small shopkeepers and taxi drivers in 1934, 35. But the other element to this, of course, is anti-Semitism because a company like Marks and Spencer, the great British high street retailer, or a company like Montague Burton, founded in Leeds, high street tailors or indeed slasinger the sports quite slasinger i hadn't thought of slasinger so slasinger slasinger jewish owned well it was it was founded by two jewish immigrants from germany well there you go perfect i'd never thought of that but that's a perfect example so this allows mosley to open up a new flank which has always been there in fascism, but not in his repertoire specifically, and that is anti-Semitism.
在这一点上，我们可能应该退后一步，谈谈英国的反犹太主义。现在，你在上周的上一集中提到，在爱德华时代，英国存在对外国人的不信任、对犹太人的仇恨，确实存在。因为在19世纪90年代和1900年代，你已经有了大约16万来自东欧、波兰、来自白俄罗斯和俄罗斯西部所谓的“定居区”（Pale of Settlement）的人涌入，那里的犹太村庄、城镇和社区一直是可怕的大屠杀的受害者。那些犹太难民特别是在东区、利兹和曼彻斯特定居。并且针对他们进行过民粹主义式的运动。1905年的保守党政府通过了《外国人法》（Aliens Act）试图限制移民，
And at this point, we should probably step back a bit and talk about anti-Semitism in Britain. Now, you mentioned in a previous episode last week that there had been distrust of foreigners, hatred of the Jews in Britain in the Edwardian period, which they had. Because in the 1890s and 1900s, you'd had the influx of, let's say, about 160,000 people from Eastern Europe, from Poland, from what was called the Pale of Settlement in Belarus and Western Russia, where Jewish villages and towns and communities have been the victim of hideous pogroms. And those Jewish refugees had settled in the East End and in Leeds and Manchester in particular. And there had been populist kind of campaigns against them. And the Tory government in 1905 had passed the Aliens Act to try and restrict immigration,
不太成功，以安抚这种草根民粹主义的焦虑。英国的犹太人总体上融合得相当好。事实上，一些犹太裔英国人融合得非常好，以至于他们是一战前爱德华七世国王圈子的一部分。所以我们提到了几次罗斯柴尔德家族（Rothschilds）。沙逊家族（Sassoons），另一个很好的例子。欧内斯特·卡塞尔（Ernest Cassel）、赫希男爵（Baron de Hirsch）。这些人被授予了爵位。他们非常成功。他们关系非常好。当然，这本身就鼓励了怨恨。所以这里一直有这种储备。我们谈到了约翰·巴肯（John Buchan）的东西。我的意思是，这实际上是一个来自《三十九级台阶》（39 Steps）的惊人引语。这个叫斯卡德（Scudder）的人，他基本上告诉
not very successfully, to sort of appease some of this kind of grassroots populist anxiety. Jewish people in Britain were pretty well integrated by and large. And in fact, some Jewish Britons were very well integrated to the extent that they were part of the circle of King Edward VII before the First World War. So we've mentioned the Rothschilds a few times. The Sassoons, another good example. Ernest Castle, Baron de Hirsch. These are people who they've been given peerages. They're very successful. They're very well-connected. And of course, that encourages resentment in itself. So there's always this kind of reservoir there. We talked about the John Buchan stuff. I mean, it's an amazing quote, actually, from the 39 Steps. This guy called Scudder, he's a person who basically tells
汉内（Hannay）情节，向汉内揭露了阴谋。他在某个时候说了这些话，资本没有良心，也没有祖国。犹太人在背后操纵。是的，他在某个时候说了这些话，资本没有良心，也没有祖国。犹太人在背后操纵。是的，先生。他就是现在统治世界的人。你会在1910年代、1920年代和1930年代初的各种英国小说和英国报纸中找到这样的情绪。但在政治上，这并不是一个巨大的问题，因为当然，在20世纪20年代没有大量的犹太人进入英国。反犹太主义，它就在那里。它在对话中，但显然从来不是选举议题。
Hannay the plot, who unveils the plot to Hannay. He says at one point, these words, capital had no conscience and no fatherland. The Jew was behind it. Yes,ne. He says at one point, these words, capital had no conscience and no fatherland. The Jew was behind it. Yes, sir. He is the man ruling the world just now. And you would find sentiments like that in all kinds of British fiction and British newspapers in the 1910s, 1920s, and early 1930s. But politically, it's not really a massive issue because of course, there aren't loads of Jewish people coming into Britain in the 1920s. And anti-Semitism, it's kind of there. It's in the conversation, but it's obviously never an election issue.
它与德国的情况完全不同，部分原因是英国的犹太人口很少且非常集中，大部分在伦敦东区。但我认为发生的事情是，大约在1933年、1934年，莫斯利出于机会主义的原因采纳了它。他显然受到希特勒的影响。他显然在寻找一个切入点，但他是否像希特勒那样有燃烧的、狂热的、个人的反犹太主义？你知道克莱夫·詹姆斯（Clive James）是怎么评价他的吗？不，继续。我提到了这个与莫斯利进行的非凡采访。我确实在YouTube上看了它。我认为非常令人不寒而栗。
It's nothing like it is in Germany, partly because the British population, Jewish population is small and very concentrated, a lot of it in the east end of London. But I think what happens is that in about 1933, 1934, Mosley takes it up for opportunistic reasons. He's obviously influenced by Hitler. He's obviously looking for an angle, but does he have a burning, fervent, personal antisemitism as Hitler did? Do you know what Clive James said about him? No, go on. I've mentioned this extraordinary interview that appeared with Mosley. And I do watch it on YouTube. It's, I think, very chilling.
克莱夫·詹姆斯，他是一位电视澳大利亚诗人、评论家、自传作家，写了一篇关于它的评论，他说，你永远不会抓到奥斯瓦尔德爵士承认反犹太主义。他所做的只是体现它。哦，非常好。是的。你认为这公平吗？我认为莫斯利，他在20世纪30年代初几乎是故意把自己变成了一个反犹太主义者。但在那之前，他会是反犹太主义者，在某种意义上
And Clive James, who is a TV Australian poet, critic, autobiographist, wrote a review of it where he said, you will never catch Sir Oswald admitting to antisemitism. All he does is embody it. Oh, very good. Yeah. Do you think that's fair? I think Mosley, he turns himself into an antis-Semite almost deliberately, I would say, in the early 1930s. But up to that point, he would have been anti-Semitic in the sense that
许多英国上层阶级的人都是反犹太主义者。也就是说，晚饭后，在波特酒和雪茄上，他会很高兴地加入关于犹太人的谈话。但我认为这对他来说不是一个统治原则，就像对20世纪20年代的许多纳粹分子一样。你知道，希特勒和希姆莱（Himmler）和那些人，我不认为他莫斯利几乎不提它。他是否受到反犹太主义者涌入法西斯运动的影响？换句话说，他是否受到他必须给这些人他们想要的东西的感觉的影响？第二个问题是，反犹太主义是否因犹太人从纳粹德国移民到英国而加剧？
lots of British people in the upper classes were anti-Semitic. That is to say, after dinner, over the port and cigars, he would have happily joined in conversations about Jews. But I don't think it was a ruling principle for him as it was for so many Nazis in the 1920s. You know, Hitler and Himmler and the people, I don't think he mostly barely mentions it. Is he being influenced by the influx of anti-Semites into the fascist movement? So in other words, is he being influenced by the sense that he has to give these people what they want? And the second question is, is anti-Semitism being stirred up by emigration of Jews from Nazi Germany to Britain?
两个答案都是肯定的。所以他绝对受到了影响。他经常在开始时受到像阿诺德·里斯（Arnold Leese）这样的人的批评，就是我们在第一集中谈到的那个“骆驼骚扰者”，他们说莫斯利在这个问题上很软弱。他周围有一些人，比如威廉·乔伊斯（William Joyce），未来的“哈罗德·霍霍”（Lord Haw-Haw），我们谈过几次，他是一个这种打手，他的脸上有一道巨大的伤疤，像一种他们称之为“格拉斯哥微笑”（Glasgow smile）的东西，因为被刺伤，有人试图用刀撕开他的嘴，乔伊斯是狂热的反犹太主义者，所以有
The two answers are yes and yes. So he's definitely being influenced. He's often being criticized at the beginning by people like Arnold Leese, the camel botherer that we talked about in episode one, who say Mosley is soft on this issue. And there are people around him, let's sayiam joyce the future lord horhor we've talked about a few times who's this kind of bruiser he has this huge scar across his face like a kind of what do they call it a glasgow smile from from being stabbed being someone tried to rip his mouth with a with a knife joyce is fanatically anti-semitic so there are Joyce is fanatically anti-Semitic.
莫斯利周围有很多狂热的反犹太主义者，他们正在把他推向那个方向。从1933年开始，这成为一个问题，因为当然，随着德国犹太人开始逃离希特勒的德国，大多数人去了美国，但不是全部。所以起初，在1933-34年，你说的是几百人，而不是几千人。我的意思是，它会在十年后变成几千人。但即使那样也引起了媒体的评论。人们谈论德国犹太人涌入英国。
So there are lots of fanatically anti-Semitic people around Mosley who are pushing him in that direction. And it becomes an issue from 1933 because, of course, as German Jews begin to get out of Hitler's Germany, most go to the United States but not all. So at first, in 1933-34, you're talking about hundreds of people, not thousands. I mean, it will become thousands later in the decade. But even that provokes press commentary. People talk about German Jews pouring into Britain.
所以他看到了一个他可以利用的问题。当然，如果你是犹太人，你很有可能会去一个已经有犹太人口的地区。所以那是曼彻斯特、利兹和伦敦东区。正是在伦敦东区，他和他的法西斯组织者同伴认为，哦，我们可以从中获利。我们可以煽动这一点。所以这会把我们带回卡布尔街，汤姆。因为大约在1935年底，所以他们在奥林匹亚事件后在布罗利奥（Brolio）度过了一年左右的完全低迷期。大约在那个时候，从伦敦东区的贝思纳尔格林（Bethnal Green）开始，他们开始在这个问题上进行竞选，而且是专门在这个问题上。所以说，你知道，你有犹太邻居，他们抢走了你们所有的工作，他们做了所有这些。
So he sees an issue that he can exploit. Now, of course, if you're Jewish, the chances are you will go to an area that already has a Jewish population. So that's Manchester, Leeds, and the East End of London. And it's in the East End of London, in particular, that he and his fellow fascist organizers think, oh, we can profit from this. We can stir this up. So this will bring us back to Cable Street, Tom. Because in about the end of 1935, so they've had a year or so in the total doldrums after the Olympia in Brolio. And about that point, starting in Bethnal Green in the east end of London, they start to campaign on this issue and this issue specifically. So to say, you know, you've got Jewish neighbors who are taking all your jobs, who are doing all this.
犹太人实际上是经济陷入混乱的背后原因。犹太人正在控制世界资本主义体系，所有这些东西。在接下来的一年左右，东区发生了很多这样的事情。所以在马丁·皮尤（Martin Pugh）的书《为黑衫军欢呼》（Hurrah for the Black Shirts）中，他引用了《标准晚报》（Evening Standard）的一篇报道，这对那些不是英国人的人来说是伦敦的晚报，由一位叫达德利·巴克（Dudley Barker）的记者撰写。他说，奥尔德盖特（Aldgate）以东的夜间旅行是一种令人震惊的经历。他说，你知道，你走在街上，总是有共产党人、法西斯分子等的街头会议。
The Jews are actually behind all the mess the economy is in. The Jews are controlling the world capitalist system, all of this sort of stuff. And for the next year or so, there's a lot of this kind of going on in the East End. So in Martin Pugh's book, Hurrah for the Black Shirts, he has a really good quotation from a report in the Evening Standard. So that's London's evening newspaper for those people who are not British, by a journalist called Dudley Barker. And he says, an evening journey east of Aldgate is an astonishing experience. And he says, you know, you go down the streets, there are always these street corner meetings of communists, of fascists, and so on.
会议通常是有序的，但他说，从主干道通往荒凉的侧街，据说那里有被讨论很多的夜间恐怖，那里讲述着安全剃须刀片插在土豆和苹果里，或者帽檐，或者管道碎片，从房前撕下的栏杆长度，以及指节铜套、刀子和钉鞋被用作武器，对抗那些误入反对派领地的游击队员，所以有一种感觉，这些是伦敦非常贫穷的地区，共产党人和英国法西斯联盟经常在同一群人中竞争。那里有柏林的某种回声。是的。纳粹前的柏林。
And the meetings are generally orderly, but he says, leading down from the main streets to the deserted side streets where the much discussed terror by night is said to stalk and where stories are told of safety razor blades stuck in potatoes and apples or the peaks of caps or bits of piping lengths of railing torn from the house fronts and knuckle dusters knives and hobnail boots used as weapons against the partisans who wander into opposition territories so there's a sort of sense of, these are very poor areas of London where the communists and the British Union of fascists are competing among the same groups of people often. And there's that echo there of Berlin. Yeah. Pre-Nazi Berlin.
完全正确。所以红色柏林，但棕衫军正在进入。完全正确。是的，就是这样，汤姆。我认为有一个回声。但这太本地化了。我的意思是，它显然从来没有达到同样的规模。而且它太本地化了，我的意思是，它显然从来没有达到同样的规模，而且它太本地化了，正如你所说，它是以斯坦利·鲍德温的英国为背景，在北安普顿（Northampton），这并没有发生，这就是杰里米·科尔宾在《晨星报》的文章中如此优美地带我们进入的那个被高度神话化的时刻的背景，也就是10月4日的卡布尔街之战。所以莫斯利决定通过在伦敦东区发起游行，将这场运动推向高潮。你无法想象比这更具煽动性、更可能引发暴力的事情。当然，他希望它具有煽动性。他想上头条。77,000人签署了
Exactly. So red Berlin, but the brown shirts are moving in. Exactly right. Yeah, that's exactly it, Tom. I think there is an echo. But it's so local. I mean, it's never on the same scale, obviously. And it's so local i mean it's never on the same scale obviously and it's so localized it's against the backdrop as you said of stanley baldwin's britain where basically in northampton this is not going on and this is the context for this much mythologized moment jeremy corbyn took us so beautifully in with in his article at the morning star which is the battle of cable streets in in October, the 4th of October. So Mosley decides he will bring this campaign to a peak by launching a march through the east end of London. You could not conceive of something more inflammatory, more likely to provoke violence. Of course, he wants it to be inflammatory. He wants to get the headlines. 77,000 people signed
一份请愿书给内政大臣，说，禁止游行。内政大臣说，不，我们在英国不禁止游行。我们是一个言论自由、自由的国家。政党可以自由游行。所以那些反对莫斯利的人说，我们将阻止他，我们将封锁他。他们的口号，是从西班牙共和党人那里借来的，西班牙共和党人在内战中的口号是，No pasaran。他们说，他们不得通过。所以10月4日，莫斯利出现了。他有3000名黑衫军。当他们接近东区时，有，谁知道呢，10万，20万，甚至30万。我的意思是，通常当人们估计人群时，他们会严重高估。我们说10万人封锁了街道。除了是杰里米·科尔宾的妈妈，他们是谁？
a petition to the Home Secretary saying, ban the march. The Home Secretary says, no, we don't ban marches in Britain. We're a country of free speech, of liberty. Political parties are free to march. So people who are opposed to Mosley say, we will stop him, we will block him. And their slogan, which is borrowed from the Spanish Republicans, Spanish Republican slogan in the Civil War is, no pasaran. And they say, they shall not pass. So on the 4th of October, Mosley pitches up. He's got 3,000 black shirts. And as they approach the East End, there are, who knows, 100,000, 200,000, maybe even 300,000. I mean, generally, when people estimate crowds, they massively overestimate. Let's say 100,000 people blocking the streets. And who are they, apart from being Jeremy Corbyn's mum?
杰里米·科尔宾当然从来不谈论它。他们很大程度上是共产党人。还有犹太人，大概？是的，当然，犹太团体。所以如果你是一个住在伦敦东区的政治活跃的犹太裔英国人，这是你的时刻。这是你站出来的机会。各种各样的左翼团体，无政府主义者，各种色彩的社会主义者，工会会员。所以所有这些团体，他们组成了这种联盟，他们站出来，他们封锁了道路，他们使法西斯分子无法进行游行。现在，如果你回到杰里米·科尔宾在那里的描述，
Jeremy Corbyn never talks about it, of course. They are communists in large part. So the British Communist Party has really... And Jews, presumably? Yes, of course, Jewish groups. So if you are a politically active Jewish Briton living in East London, this is your moment. This is your chance to make a stand. Left-wing groups of various kinds, anarchists, socialists of various hues, trade unionists. So all these sorts of groups, they form this kind of coalition, and they make a stand, and they block the road road and they make it impossible for the fascists to do their march. Now, if you go back to Jeremy Corbyn's description there,
我们与法西斯主义进行了斗争。这就是那种事情，这是安提法（Antifa）运动，美国的反法西斯运动。有时有人说它会从卡布尔街之战中汲取灵感。显然，这是英国，不是美国，但这是他们胜利名单中的日期之一。他们说，我们与法西斯主义进行了斗争。有所有这些描述，建造路障，使用棍棒，使用石头，投掷椅子腿，所有这些东西。把弹珠滚到马蹄下。但实际上，最后一件事告诉你一些事情。
we fought fascism. And this is the kind of thing, it's the Antifa movement, the anti-fascist movement in the United States. It's sometimes said it would take an inspiration from the Battle of Cable Street. Obviously, it's Britain, it's not America, but it's one of the dates in their kind of litany of victories. And they said, we fought fascism. There are all these descriptions, building barricades, using sticks, using rocks, throwing chair legs, all of this stuff. Rolling marbles under the hooves of the horses. But actually, that last thing tells you something.
他们实际上根本没有与法西斯分子战斗。这是人们对卡布尔街之战理解错误的一件事。他们实际上是在与警察战斗。法西斯分子和反法西斯分子实际上从未发生过冲突，因为警察在他们中间，所以战斗实际上是在警察和反法西斯团体成员之间，大概共产党人会说警察只是资本主义国家的准军事机构，而法西斯分子是资本主义的另一种表现。这都差不多。是的，他们会。我想如果你是一个持证的共产党人，你会这么说。我的意思是，如果你是一个工会会员，你不一定这么想。或者如果你是一个某种
They actually don't fight fascists at all. This is one thing that people get wrong about the Battle of Cable Street. They actually fight the police. The fascists and the anti-fascists never actually come to blows because the police are in between them so the fighting is actually between the police and elements of the kind of anti-fascist group presumably though the communists would say that the police are merely the paramilitary apparatus of the capitalist state and that the fascists are another expression of capitalists. And it's all much of a muchness. Yeah, they would. I suppose you would say that if you were a card-carrying communist. I mean, if you're a trade unionist, you might not necessarily think that. Or if you're a sort
左翼同路人，或者确实，如果你是一个只想为他的社区挺身而出的犹太活动家。我的意思是，别忘了，大多数人并没有参与这场战斗。但确实发生的战斗并没有像人们想象的那样涉及法西斯分子。因为他们只是出现，警察就把他们送回去了。是的。警察说你不能这样做。他们就放弃了。你必须放弃并回家。现在，杰里米·科尔宾的一件事，我的意思是，我不是在抨击杰里米·科尔宾。上帝知道我在我的职业生涯中已经做了足够多的那种事，但这一次，我不是专门抨击杰里米·科尔宾，因为他所说的是
of left-wing fellow traveller, or indeed, if you're a Jewish activist who just wants to stand up for his community. I mean, don't forget, most people aren't doing this fighting. But the fighting that does happen doesn't really actually involve the fascists as much as people think it does. Because they just turn up and the police send them back. Yeah. And the police say you can't do it. And they kind of give up. You've got to give up and go home. Now, the one thing that Jeremy Corbyn, I mean, I'm not knocking Jeremy Corbyn. God knows I've done enough of that in my professional career, but for once, I'm not knocking Jeremy Corbyn specifically because what he's saying is
绝对是卡布尔街神话的典型。我们阻止了他们。这是那个时刻，你知道，所有那种东西。当然，人们想相信它，但它是完全错误的，因为它不是那个时刻，它也没有从长远上阻止他们。所以你是在抨击杰里米·科尔宾？我不是专门谈论。我的意思是，他只是在说每个人都在说的话。但实际上，两件事发生了。第一，在卡布尔街之战之后，东区有更多非常、非常热情地参加的英国法西斯联盟会议。实际上，在某些方面，这对法西斯分子来说是很好的宣传。他们有很多会议，参加人数非常多。另一件事，特别分部（Special Branch），他们正在监视
absolutely typical of the mythology of Cable Street. We stopped them. This was the moment, you know, all that kind of thing. And of course, people want to believe it, but it is completely wrong, because it wasn't the moment and it didn't stop them in the long term. So you are knocking Jeremy Corbyn? I'm not talking specifically. I mean, he's just saying what everybody else says. But actually, two things happen. One, there are lots more very, very enthusiastically attended British Union of Fascist meetings in the East End in the aftermath of the Battle of Cable Street. It's actually, in some ways, good publicity for the fascists. They have loads of meetings, very well attended. The other thing, Special Branch, who are monitoring
他们，对于那些不是英国人的人来说，那是苏格兰场的一种专业元素，他们估计实际上英国法西斯联盟的伦敦成员在卡布尔街之战后增加了。它实际上吸引了人们加入他们。实际上，伦敦最严重的反犹太暴力事件发生在卡布尔街之战后的那个周末，在斯特普尼（Stepney）。200名黑衫军，那种年轻人，十几岁，他们横冲直撞，砸毁犹太企业。换句话说，这根本不是一个让法西斯分子收拾行李回家的时刻。在某些方面，它
them for those people who are not British, that's a sort of specialist element of Scotland Yard, they estimated that actually the London membership of the British Union of Fascists went up after the Battle of Cable Street. It actually attracted people to join them. And there was actually the worst anti-Semitic violence in London happened the weekend after the Battle of Cable Street in Stepney. 200 black shirts, kind of young men, teenagers, they run amok, smashing Jewish businesses. So in other words, this isn't a moment that makes the fascists pack up and go home at all. In some ways, it
壮大了他们。但我的意思是，我可以理解这一点。你可以打言论自由牌，例如，尽管大概法西斯分子从长远来看想废除言论自由。从长远来看，是的。你知道，他们可以说，哦，我们的言论自由被剥夺了，所有那种东西。他们可以打受害者牌。我可以理解人们会团结在那一点上。但从长远来看，法西斯气球里的空气不是在漏掉吗？从这个意义上说，短期激增，但长期衰落。是的，我认为这是一个很好的观点。
emboldens them. But I mean, I can understand that. You can play the free speech card, for instance, even though presumably the fascists want to get rid of free speech in the long run. In the long run, yeah. You know, they can say, oh, our free speech has been denied, all that kind of thing. They can play the victim card. And I can understand that people kind of rallying to that. But in the long run, is the air not going out of the fascist balloon? In that sense, short-term spike, but long-term decline. Yeah, I think that's a good point.
我认为关于反犹太主义的事情，莫斯利的许多这种诡计、策略都是如此，它会给你一定程度的支持和关注，但这必然是有限的。某种糖分冲击。糖分冲击，完全正确。所以它得到了那种喜欢打架的额外几千名成员的糖分冲击。他们对暴力感到非常兴奋。他们想要有人来责怪。坦率地说，英国没有足够多的人
I think the thing about the anti-Semitism, it's true of a lot of Mosley's kind of wheezes, his stratagems, is that it will get you a certain amount of support and an amount of attention, but that is necessarily limited. Kind of sugar rush. A sugar rush, exactly. So it gets the sugar rush of an extra few thousand members who love the thought of a punch up. They're very excited by the violence. They want someone to blame. Frankly, there are not enough people who are in Britain who are
主要受政治反犹太主义的驱动。有很多人有反犹太偏见。他们读过所有这些书，但他们并不关心到加入BUF并为之工作。但大概这也是在发生？是的。在随后的几年里，在德国，纳粹对犹太人的骚扰和迫害变得越来越明显。是的。英国难道没有一种感觉……我的意思是，我知道显然英国不会为了保卫犹太人而参战。我的意思是，这显然不是事实。但确实有一种感觉，不是吗，人们越来越，如果不是感到恐惧，那么也会对
motivated primarily by political antisemitism. There are lots of people with antisemitic prejudices. They've read all these books, but they don't care enough to join the BUF and to work for it. But presumably also, this is happening in? Yes. In the years that follow in Germany, the Nazi harassment and persecution of the Jews is becoming more and more obvious. Yes. And isn't there a sense in Britain that... I mean, I know obviously Britain doesn't go to war to defend the Jews. I mean, that's clearly not the case. But there is a sense, isn't there, that people are increasingly, if not horrified, then unsettled by what's
德国发生的事情感到不安。是的，我同意。我认为反犹太主义，它曾经是完全的，这听起来会很令人震惊，反犹太主义在20世纪20年代初是受人尊敬的。你可以去参加一个国家最杰出人物的晚宴，说一些关于犹太人的话，人们甚至不会眨眼。我认为到20世纪30年代末，由于与纳粹主义以及德国发生的事情的联系，有一种感觉，它变得更加有毒了。
happening in Germany. Yes, I agree. I think anti-Semitism, which had been perfectly, this will sound shocking, anti-Semitism had been respectable in the early 1920s. You could go to a dinner party of the most eminent people in the land and say things about Jews and people wouldn't bat an eyelid. I think by the late 1930s, by association with Nazism and what's been happening in Germany, there is a sense that it is much more toxic.
是的。下一集的剧透，但尤妮蒂·米特福德（Unity Mitford），她对自己的反犹太主义非常公开，这给她的家庭带来了巨大的尴尬，它被视为是不可接受的。如果你是，如果你是，如果你想对卡布尔街发表另一个观点，汤姆，你可以说实际上正是那样的示威活动，帮助它变得有毒。
Yeah. Spoiler for the next episode, but Unity Mitford, she's very overt about her antisemitism and this causes her family huge embarrassment and it is seen as being unacceptable. And if you were, if you were being, if you wanted to make another point about cable street, Tom, you could say that it's actually demonstrations like that, that help to toxify it.
是的。你知道，实际上它需要人们站出来说，这是不可接受的。我想是的。所以我认为从这个意义上说，杰里米·科尔宾说它，你知道，
Yeah. You know, that actually it requires people to stand up and to say, this is not acceptable. I think so. So I think in that sense, Jeremy Corbyn isn't wrong to say that it, you know,
他们采取了立场，并没有错。我的意思是，这个播客确实被精心制作，汤姆，作为一种“科尔宾洗白”我们自己的方式。所以说到这里，让我们休息一下。在《历史的余味》中非常出人意料。当我们回来时，让我们看看战争的酝酿以及英国法西斯分子在假战期间以及之后发生了什么。太棒了。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。
they took a stand. I mean, this podcast has really been crafted, Tom, as a way of Corbyn washing ourselves. So on that note, let's take a break. Very unexpected on the rest of history. And when we come back, let's look at the buildup to the war and what happens to the fascists in Britain during the Phony War and then after. Splendid. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是您每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果您想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets,
请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestis rest is entertainment.com，那是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》，我们正在继续我们的英国法西斯主义系列节目，卡布尔街之战已经被反法西斯分子打赢了。多米尼克，战争的乌云正在欧洲上空变暗。所以我们正在走向绥靖政策和战争的酝酿，然后是战争的爆发。法西斯分子在英国的这一过程中扮演了什么角色？所以关于这一点最迷人的事情是，虽然我们当然将法西斯主义与军国主义和侵略性民族主义联系在一起，并且我们基本上希望它入侵和征服，但英国法西斯主义是
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestis rest is entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com hello welcome back to the rest is history we're continuing our series on british fascism and the battle of cable street has been fought and won by the anti-fascists. Dominic, the storm clouds of war are darkening over Europe. So we are coming to appeasement and the build-up to war and then the outbreak of war. What is the role of the fascists in this in Britain? So the fascinating thing about this is, whereas of course we associate fascism with militarism and with aggressive nationalism, and we basically want it to invade and conquer, British fascism is the
20世纪30年代末的和平党。它是超绥靖政策的政党。它是说我们不应该为了波兰而参战的政党。但实际上，我们迅速跳过的一件事，我们应该只是点头示意，有一个危机是法西斯分子可能希望从中获利的，那就是1936年的退位危机。所以人们有时指着说，这个人可能是法西斯分子的人，最突出的是国王，爱德华八世，他从1936年1月统治到1936年12月。他认识莫斯利。他在1935年见过莫斯利，所以当莫斯利是英国法西斯联盟的领袖时，并和他谈论过法西斯主义，说，你在搞什么？你对什么感兴趣？爱德华八世，他是那一代人。
peace party in the late 1930s. It's the party of ultra-appeasement. It is the party that says we shouldn't go to war over Poland. But actually, one thing we've quickly skipped over that we should just make a nod to is there is one crisis that the fascists could conceivably have hoped to profit from, and that is the abdication crisis of 1936. So the most prominent person that people have sometimes pointed a finger at and said, could this person have been a fascist is the King, Edward VIII, who reigns from January 1936 to December 1936. He knew Mosley. He had met Mosley in 1935, so when Mosley was leader of the British Union of Fascists, and had talked to him about fascism and said, what are you up to? What are you interested in? Edward VIII, he is of that generation.
20世纪30年代后期的和平党。这是一个极端绥靖政策的政党。它主张我们不应该为了波兰而开战。但实际上，我们快速跳过了一点，即我们应该提一下，法西斯分子可能希望从中获利的一场危机，那就是1936年的退位危机。因此，人们有时会指责并怀疑是否可能是法西斯分子的人，最突出的就是爱德华八世国王，他在1936年1月至1936年12月期间在位。他认识莫斯利。他在1935年见过莫斯利，当时莫斯利是英国法西斯联盟的领导人，他曾与他谈论过法西斯主义，并问他：你在搞什么？你对什么感兴趣？爱德华八世，他就是那一代人。
He is one of those people who chafes at the old men, who says, I mean, you mentioned him earlier, Tom, saying something must be done. He's impatient. He's mercurial. He has a taste for married women. He's actually quite Mosley-like, isn't he? I mean, he's not a Nazi. Sometimes it's sort of said, he wasn't a Nazi, but he is sympathetic to German aristocrats and people like that, ambassadors and dignitaries and things who say to him, oh, we've been very hard done by. We just want to regain our pride and all that sort of thing. And actually, that's one of the things that makes Stanley Baldwin distrust Edward VIII and think he's going to be very unreliable as king. We're going to have to watch him. Then when the Wallace Simpson thing blows up, the abdication, I'm sure one day we'll do an episode about the abdication crisis because
他属于那种对老一辈人感到恼火的人，就像你之前提到的，汤姆，他说必须要做点什么。他缺乏耐心，反复无常，还对已婚女性情有独钟。他其实很像莫斯利，不是吗？我的意思是，他不是纳粹。有时人们会说，他不是纳粹，但他同情德国贵族和类似的人，比如那些对他说“哦，我们受到了很不公正的对待，我们只是想恢复尊严”之类的外交官和政要。事实上，这正是斯坦利·鲍德温不信任爱德华八世，并认为他作为国王会非常不可靠的原因之一。我们得盯着他。后来当沃利斯·辛普森事件爆发，也就是退位事件时，我相信总有一天我们会做一期关于退位危机的节目，因为
it's perennially fascinating to people. So this is the Megan of the 1930s. The Megan moment when he decides he wants to get it on with an American divorcee, Wallace Simpson. And Baldwin says to him, the prime minister says, you're going to have to choose between the crown and the American divorcee. Mosley campaigns for the King. So there are stories about- As Winston Churchill does, of course. Yes.
它对人们来说一直有着持久的吸引力。所以这就是20世纪30年代的梅根时刻。当他决定要和一位美国离婚女性沃利斯·辛普森在一起时，鲍德温对他说，首相说，你必须在王位和这位美国离婚女性之间做出选择。莫斯利为国王竞选。所以有一些关于——当然，温斯顿·丘吉尔也这么做了。是的。
Actually, so it's an interesting, this is an interesting moment of alignment between the British Union of Fascists and Winston Churchill. They're both of the King's party, as it was kind of called. So the BUF actually pay for a loudspeaker van to go up and down Whitehall broadcasting, stand by the king. That is the message of Moseley in this time of crisis. And there's a story that will appeal to our Rest Is History guest, Dan Jackson, a man who loves a bit of Newcastle history. So Newcastle upon time, black shirts jog around the city, giving out leaflets and chanting two, four, six, eight, the king must not abdicate.
事实上，这是英国法西斯联盟和温斯顿·丘吉尔之间一个有趣的结盟时刻。他们都属于所谓的“国王派”。所以英国法西斯联盟甚至花钱雇了一辆装有扩音器的货车在白厅来回广播，支持国王。这就是莫斯利在那个危机时刻传达的信息。有一个故事会吸引我们的《历史的余味》嘉宾丹·杰克逊，一个热爱纽卡斯尔历史的人。在纽卡斯尔，黑衫军在城里慢跑，分发传单并高喊：二、四、六、八，国王绝不能退位。
But he does abdicate. And so off he goes. And actually, he's then not part of the equation. And actually, this doesn't really win mostly much extra support, which is a much better issue for him. And it's a really good issue for him. This is the shocking and surprising thing for many listeners, I imagine, is the thing about peace with Germany and no to war.
但他还是退位了。于是他离开了。实际上，他随后就不再是这个等式的一部分了。而且，这并没有为莫斯利赢得多少额外的支持，这对他来说是一个更好的议题。这对他来说是一个非常好的议题。我想这对许多听众来说是令人震惊和惊讶的，那就是关于与德国和平、拒绝战争的问题。
So as the storm clouds gather, Tom, the more they gather, the more he hammers home the war issue. Well, it's an anti-war coalition, isn't it? Yeah, stop the war. It's a stop-the-war coalition. This is a very Jeremy Corbyn-themed episode. So they say, you know, absolutely no war for Eastern Europe. In two years, their support goes from 6,000 members to about 30,000 members.
所以当乌云密布时，汤姆，乌云越聚越多，他越是强调战争问题。嗯，这是一个反战联盟，对吧？是的，停止战争。这是一个“停止战争”联盟。这一集非常有杰里米·科尔宾的主题。所以他们说，你知道，绝对不要为东欧而战。在两年内，他们的支持者从6000名成员增加到约30000名成员。
So a fivefold increase by 1939 on this issue. They say the Tories and Labour are warmongers. We will revise the Treaty of Versailles. Appeasement has not gone far enough. All of this kind of thing. They, again, as they've done so often, they make women very prominent in the campaigns. So there will be poster parades of fascist women. The posters carry the slogan, our children were young in 1914. Have we brought them up for war?
所以到1939年，在这个问题上增长了五倍。他们说保守党和工党是战争贩子。我们将修订《凡尔赛条约》。绥靖政策还不够深入。诸如此类。他们再次像往常一样，让女性在竞选中发挥突出作用。所以会有法西斯女性的海报游行。海报上写着标语：我们的孩子在1914年还很年轻。我们把他们养大就是为了战争吗？
And you can absolutely see if they downplay the fascist logo, bury that in the small print, a lot of people, you're on the streets of up for war. And you can absolutely see if they've downplayed the fascist logo, buried that in the small print, a lot of people, you're on the streets of Aberystwyth or whatever, and you're walking along and you see these characters and you think- Are you in favor of war? Yeah. Who's going to say? No, I'm not. Well, join the fascists. So I'll tell you what I found so interesting reading up about this. So as you
你可以完全看出，如果他们淡化法西斯标志，把它埋在小字里，很多人，你在阿伯里斯特威斯或其他什么地方的街上，你走着走着看到这些人，你会想——你支持战争吗？是的。谁会说“不，我不支持”？好吧，加入法西斯吧。所以我告诉你我读到这些时觉得多有趣。所以当你
get into 1939 they're still making excuses they make excuses for hitler they are saying well he's dismembered czechoslovakia but that was never a real country you know it was a contrived and as it gets to poland they say poland is corrupt it's being used as a puppet for the West. So why should Britain shed blood for the sake of this rotting confederacy of cash and corruption? Why do we have to be allied to every little country in the East of Europe? This strangulation policy, they're saying we're trying to strangle Germany. We're making Germany feel embattled. This will throw Europe into war. It's impossible to read this without thinking of all those people who say,
进入1939年，他们还在找借口，他们为希特勒找借口，他们说，好吧，他肢解了捷克斯洛伐克，但那从来都不是一个真正的国家，你知道，它是人为拼凑的。当谈到波兰时，他们说波兰是腐败的，它被用作西方的傀儡。那么英国为什么要为了这个腐烂的金钱和腐败的联盟而流血呢？为什么我们必须与东欧的每一个小国结盟？这种扼杀政策，他们说我们试图扼杀德国。我们让德国感到四面楚歌。这会把欧洲拖入战争。如果不联想到那些说……的人，就不可能读到这些，
why are we throwing this money into the sink of Ukraine? We have actually provoked Russia by expanding. The rhetoric is, by the way, for the avoidance of doubt, I'm not saying these people are fascists in the 21st century necessarily, but I'm saying there's a remarkable similarity in the rhetoric. No, but I think what you're saying is that because we know what the Nazis do, because we have the association of the word fascist with death camps, with the Holocaust, with unspeakable crimes and horrors, we may close our eyes to aspects of fascism that before the war would appeal to all kinds of different constituencies. So if you are anti-war, they would appeal to you. If you're an environmentalist, they might appeal to you. If you're on the left, might appeal to you.
为什么我们要把钱扔进乌克兰这个无底洞？我们实际上通过扩张挑衅了俄罗斯。顺便说一句，为了避免歧义，我并不是说这些人一定是21世纪的法西斯分子，但我想说的是，这种修辞有着惊人的相似之处。不，但我认为你想说的是，因为我们知道纳粹做了什么，因为我们将“法西斯”这个词与死亡集中营、大屠杀、无法言说的罪行和恐怖联系在一起，我们可能会对法西斯主义在战前吸引各种不同群体的方面视而不见。所以如果你是反战的，他们会吸引你。如果你是环保主义者，他们可能会吸引你。如果你是左翼，也可能会吸引你。
Tom, you were going to mention Scotland. Yeah. So there are people, there are nationalists in Scotland who are pretty sympathetic. I think by and large, I mean, the figures in the SNP who are sympathetic to Germany in this period are doing it because they are anti-English rather than because they're pro-fascist. But there are aspects of a fascist program that people can identify with in ways that perhaps would be inexplicable to people today. If you're anti-war, if you're pro-environment, there are aspects of the fascist policies that might appeal to you. You know, if you think sometimes parliament isn't working, we're really let down by our leaders.
汤姆，你刚才要提到苏格兰。是的。所以有一些人，苏格兰的民族主义者，他们相当同情。我认为总的来说，苏格兰民族党中那些在这一时期同情德国的人，是因为他们反英，而不是因为他们亲法西斯。但法西斯纲领中确实有一些方面是人们可以认同的，这在今天的人看来可能无法理解。如果你反战，如果你支持环保，法西斯政策中确实有一些方面可能会吸引你。你知道，如果你有时认为议会运作不灵，我们真的被领导人辜负了。
I mean, who wouldn't think that? They're all the same. They're all the same, or they're just self-aggrandizing shits. Yeah, I absolutely agree with that. I do think they're all the same, absolutely useless, get rid of a lot of them, is a stepping stone of a kind to fascism. However, against that, I mean, we mustn't become too revisionist because, of course, it's absolutely evident by this point that Hitler is going to be capable of unspeakable crimes. And so the fascists in Britain must be tarred with association. Yes, I think they are.
我的意思是，谁不会这么想呢？他们都一样。他们都一样，或者他们只是自大的混蛋。是的，我完全同意这一点。我确实认为他们都一样，完全没用，应该清理掉他们中的很多人，这算是通往法西斯主义的一块垫脚石。然而，反过来说，我们绝不能变得太修正主义，因为当然，到目前为止，希特勒显然有能力犯下无法言说的罪行。所以英国的法西斯分子必须被这种联系所玷污。是的，我认为他们是。
Although, this is why their support doesn't go higher. Although they're probably more respectable in 1939 than they were in 1936 or so, because they've basically really gone in hard on this issue of peace and opposition to war. But I agree with you, obviously, for most people, for most sane people in 1939, the British Union of Fascists is a poisonous party. The black shirts, the violence, the antisemitism. So war is declared and Moseley is allowed to campaign for peace against the government for nine months. I find that amazing. I mean, it's a tribute either to the British
虽然，这就是为什么他们的支持率没有更高的原因。尽管他们在1939年可能比1936年左右更受尊重，因为他们基本上在和平和反对战争这个问题上立场非常坚定。但我同意你的看法，显然，对于1939年的大多数人，大多数理智的人来说，英国法西斯联盟是一个有毒的政党。黑衫军、暴力、反犹太主义。所以战争爆发了，莫斯利被允许在九个月内公开反对政府争取和平。我觉得这太不可思议了。我的意思是，这要么归功于英国
traditions of free speech or of complacency or of the sense that, because as we will find out in the next episode, Churchill actually has family links to Moseley by marriage. Well, it's Churchill who locks him up. I know. That Churchill's not going soft on him. But there is a sense, I think, in which perhaps the British government is not going after Mosley because he is still seen as being one of us. There may be a slight element of that, but I think it's actually more that for the first
言论自由的传统，要么归功于自满，或者是因为——正如我们在下一集中会发现的那样——丘吉尔实际上通过婚姻与莫斯利有亲戚关系。好吧，是丘吉尔把他关起来的。我知道。丘吉尔对他并没有心软。但我认为，在某种程度上，英国政府没有对付莫斯利，是因为他仍然被视为“我们自己人”。这可能有一点因素，但我认为更多是因为在最初的
nine months or so during the so-called phony war, the Chamberlain government just thinks, if you haven't committed treason, we're not going to lock you up. And the truth of the matter is, and this was a slightly odd thing to think because we're so used to thinking the fascist is inherently treasonous, that most of them haven't committed treason. I mean, Mosley has not committed treason. He's not giving secrets to the Germans or anything like that. Well, again, Dominic, and this is why the Mitfords will be so interesting.
九个月左右，也就是所谓的“假战”期间，张伯伦政府只是认为，如果你没有犯下叛国罪，我们就不会把你关起来。事实是——这有点奇怪，因为我们习惯于认为法西斯分子本质上就是叛国者——他们中的大多数人并没有犯下叛国罪。我的意思是，莫斯利没有犯下叛国罪。他没有向德国人泄露任何秘密之类的东西。好吧，多米尼克，这就是为什么米特福德家族会如此有趣。
This is just a third of a three-part prologue. Lord and Lady Riesdale, the mother and father of the Mitford sisters, and indeed their one son, their reaction to the outbreak of war is fascinating because it exemplifies the way in which very far-right figures react to the declaration of war. I will say no more than that. Oh, it's so exciting, Tom. It's an intriguing example of the tensions there. So a few fascists go abroad william joyce is the most famous he's a man who's cropped up again and again in this
这只是三部分序言的三分之一。里斯代尔勋爵和夫人，米特福德姐妹的父母，以及他们唯一的儿子，他们对战争爆发的反应非常迷人，因为它体现了极右翼人物对宣战的反应方式。我只能说这么多了。哦，太令人兴奋了，汤姆。这是一个关于紧张局势的有趣例子。所以一些法西斯分子去了国外，威廉·乔伊斯是最著名的，他是一个在这个
podcast so he's the guy with the the slash across his face the joker yeah he looks like the joker he has been always on the the more violent the more extreme wing of moses movement he goes off he says i'm going to go and become a german and he spends the war broadcasting propaganda into britain which is listened to by colossal quantities of people berlin calling berlin calling it's like we've got him on the podcast i'm chilling a chilling resemblance but a chilling but instructive resemblance i would say tom he's broadcasting to britain he's sort of saying oh you're all the tools of jewish finance and all this kind of stuff and loads and loads of people listen because they're fascinated, not because they believe him. But Mosley doesn't go. Mosley says, I'm not going to fight in defense of Poland,
播客中反复出现的人。所以他就是那个脸上有一道伤疤的人，小丑。是的，他看起来像小丑。他一直处于莫斯利运动中更暴力、更极端的派系。他离开了，他说我要去成为一个德国人，他在战争期间向英国广播宣传，被大量的人收听。“柏林呼叫，柏林呼叫”，就像我们请他上了播客一样。一种令人不寒而栗的相似，但我会说，汤姆，这是一种令人不寒而栗但具有启发性的相似。他向英国广播，他说，哦，你们都是犹太金融的工具之类的，很多人听是因为他们感到好奇，而不是因为他们相信他。但莫斯利没有走。莫斯利说，我不会为了保卫波兰而战，
but if my members want to defend their country, they're very free to do so. So he's trying to tread a fine line. He thinks there's going to be a great coup or a collapse and that he can walk in. He has this delusion that the RAF will support him one day to seize power. But then we get to May 1940, Churchill wants to take a harder line. Churchill's cabinet amends the Emergency Powers Act, Regulation 18B it's called, and they say we can detain people whose movements have or have had in the past an association with foreign belligerents. So Mosley's arrested. In total, I think almost 750 fascists are arrested. But interestingly, the aristocrats aren't. So all the kind of the Duke of this, the Marquess of Tavistock,
但如果我的成员想保卫他们的国家，他们完全可以这样做。所以他试图走一条微妙的路线。他认为会发生一场伟大的政变或崩溃，他可以趁机介入。他有一种妄想，认为英国皇家空军有一天会支持他夺取政权。但后来到了1940年5月，丘吉尔想要采取更强硬的路线。丘吉尔的内阁修订了《紧急权力法》，即所谓的“18B条例”，他们说我们可以拘留那些过去或现在与外国交战国有联系的人。所以莫斯利被捕了。总共，我想有近750名法西斯分子被捕。但有趣的是，贵族们没有被捕。所以所有那些什么公爵、塔维斯托克侯爵，
the Lord Brockett, all these kinds of characters, they're all let off scot-free. You can't arrest an aristocrat. Now, the funny thing is that people who've written about this generally say, Mosley is actually, I mean, this is a weird thing to say, given that basically he's the great villain. He's actually a bit hard done by because he wasn't actually a traitor. He'd been to Germany. He was always more drawn to Italy and to Mussolini than he was to Hitler.
布罗基特勋爵，所有这些角色，他们都逍遥法外。你不能逮捕一个贵族。现在，有趣的是，写过这件事的人通常会说，莫斯利实际上——我的意思是，考虑到他基本上是个大反派，这话说出来很奇怪——他实际上有点被冤枉了，因为他并不是真正的叛徒。他去过德国。他总是比希特勒更倾向于意大利和墨索里尼。
But there's no evidence that he has been supporting Germany in the Second World War or giving them any information or giving them any help. Well, Dominic, unless his wife, his sister-in-law, perhaps. I mean, we'll touch on this in our next episode. But Tom, you're not imprisoned because of what your wife and your sister-in-law have done. Well, you might be in a national emergency. Well, exactly, in a national emergency. So there's some argument that Churchill does this to frighten the Americans. So that Churchill insists on this being done because he wants to promote, you know, there's a new start after Chamberlain has gone, more dynamic leadership. And then actually he wants to say, look,
但没有证据表明他在第二次世界大战中支持德国，或者向他们提供任何信息或帮助。好吧，多米尼克，除非他的妻子，他的小姨子，也许。我的意思是，我们会在下一集中谈到这一点。但汤姆，你不会因为你妻子和你小姨子做过的事而被监禁。好吧，在国家紧急状态下你可能会。好吧，确实，在国家紧急状态下。所以有人认为丘吉尔这样做是为了吓唬美国人。丘吉尔坚持要这样做，因为他想推动，你知道，在张伯伦下台后有一个新的开始，更具活力的领导力。然后实际上他想说，看，
we have this terrible fifth column in Britain. Well, yes, because he does say, doesn't he, that if the Germans occupy Britain, then probably they'll set up some Vichy type government run by Mosley. Yeah. Which is actually- That's probably not true. It would have been Lloyd George or someone like that. Exactly. So had the Germans arrived in Britain, I think there are a couple of possibilities. One is they pick a sort of a weedy, tweedy kind of tory lord halifax lord halifax the other is they go for a more martial pay town kind of scenario in which case lloyd george does seem like the obvious person lloyd
我们在英国有这个可怕的第五纵队。嗯，是的，因为他确实说过，不是吗？如果德国人占领英国，那么他们可能会建立某种由莫斯利领导的维希式政府。是的。这实际上——那可能不是真的。那可能是劳合·乔治或类似的人。没错。所以如果德国人到达英国，我认为有两种可能性。一种是他们选择一个软弱的、粗呢风格的托利党人，哈利法克斯勋爵，哈利法克斯勋爵；另一种是他们选择更具军事色彩的贝当式方案，在这种情况下，劳合·乔治确实看起来是显而易见的人选，劳合·
george who would you know who's certain sympathies with hitler well hitler's rise to power he had yeah lloyd george who, who had sometimes said suspicious things. Lloyd George, who, of course, had been perfectly happy to work with the conservatives in the First World War, had flogged all his peerages, had been very corrupt. It's possible to see a scenario in which Lloyd George thinks, I'm the saviour of my country. I will put us back together. I will do what has to be done, all that kind of thing. Anyway, I think it is unlikely that Mosley would have been, it's not impossible.
乔治，他（你知道）对希特勒有某种同情。嗯，希特勒上台时他确实有。劳合·乔治，他有时会说一些可疑的话。劳合·乔治，当然，在第一次世界大战中与保守党合作得非常愉快，他卖掉了所有的爵位，非常腐败。可以想象一个场景，劳合·乔治认为，我是我国家的救星。我会把我们重新团结起来。我会做必须做的事，诸如此类。总之，我认为莫斯利不太可能，虽然也不是不可能。
I mean, quizzling in Norway. Anyway. But the thing is that actually Hitler doesn't really respect Mosley. Yes. He sees him as a loser. However, Dominic, there are people in Mosley's immediate family circle on whom Hitler is considerably keener. Right. This is another trailer for your next episode. In our next episode, we will look at two of those in particular. One of them,
我的意思是，挪威的吉斯林。总之。但问题是，希特勒其实并不怎么尊重莫斯利。是的。他把他看作一个失败者。然而，多米尼克，在莫斯利的直系亲属圈子里，有一些人是希特勒相当看重的。对。这是你下一集的另一个预告。在下一集中，我们将特别关注其中的两位。其中之一，
Diana, Lady Mosley, who had been Diana Mitford, is his wife. And the other, Unity Mitford, is his sister-in-law. And they get up very close to Hitler, unity perhaps exceptionally close to Hitler. And so in our final episode, Dominic, we will be looking at the Mitford specifically and seeing what kind of mirror they hold up. Tom, I find it absolutely bizarre that in all the episodes we've done in the rest of history, the one that you've put more effort into is the Mitford. I'm just teeing up. More than the Rubicon more than muhammad more than all your other enthusiasts more than dinosaurs tom who would have thought it and all you care about is the mitfords i'm just teeing it up because i think it is a brilliant way to look at what is going on
戴安娜，莫斯利夫人，也就是戴安娜·米特福德，是他的妻子。另一位，尤妮蒂·米特福德，是他的小姨子。她们与希特勒走得很近，尤妮蒂可能与希特勒走得异常近。所以，在我们的最后一集中，多米尼克，我们将专门研究米特福德家族，看看她们照出了什么样的镜子。汤姆，我觉得非常奇怪，在我们《历史的余味》做过的所有剧集中，你投入最多精力的一集竟然是关于米特福德家族的。我只是在铺垫。比卢比孔河，比穆罕默德，比你所有的其他热情，比恐龙还要多，汤姆，谁会想到呢？你关心的竟然全是米特福德家族。我只是在铺垫，因为我认为这是一个绝佳的视角，可以观察
in the relationship of british fascists and the nazis and hitler specifically and then into the war what happens to not just mosley but to his wife and then what happens to the the fascists during the war after the war and how british fascism is remembered and commemorated right the way up to the present day tom i don't want to um upset you but theo our producer says that your episode on the mitford sounds way more fun he writes than all the other episodes you've done in the rest of his history well i'm not entirely going to disagree with that i think it is i mean it is an amazing story i know that lots and lots of people will be familiar with the story but if you're not it's an incredible way i think to finish off this this series on british fascism so we leave oswald mosley he and the um the male fascists where are they all put
英国法西斯分子与纳粹和希特勒之间的关系，以及进入战争后，不仅是莫斯利，还有他的妻子发生了什么，以及战争期间和战后法西斯分子发生了什么，以及英国法西斯主义是如何被记忆和纪念的，一直延续到今天。汤姆，我不想让你难过，但我们的制片人西奥说，你关于米特福德的那一集听起来比你在《历史的余味》中做的所有其他剧集都要有趣得多。好吧，我不会完全不同意这一点。我认为确实是这样，我的意思是，这是一个了不起的故事。我知道很多人都会熟悉这个故事，但如果你不熟悉，我认为这是结束这个关于英国法西斯主义系列节目的绝佳方式。所以我们离开奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利，他和那些男性法西斯分子，他们都被关在哪里？
they're all put in bri Brixton. In Brixton. The women are generally sent to Holloway. Some of them go on hunger strike. Most of them are actually released by 1942, but Mosley is still there. So we'll leave him there, Tom, in prison behind bars. British fascism has been dissipated. It's completely lost its momentum because, of course, Britain is now fighting a great crusade against international fascism. But we will return in a few minutes, for those of you who are members
他们都被关在布里克斯顿。在布里克斯顿。女性通常被送到霍洛威。她们中的一些人进行了绝食抗议。她们中的大多数人实际上在1942年就被释放了，但莫斯利还在那里。所以我们就把他留在那里，汤姆，在监狱的铁窗后。英国法西斯主义已经消散了。它完全失去了动力，因为当然，英国现在正在进行一场反对国际法西斯主义的伟大十字军东征。但我们几分钟后会回来，为那些是我们俱乐部成员的人。
of our own club. I don't know where I was going to go with that. I considered for a moment embarking on a very risky parallel. No, don't. And then I thought, no, I won't. If you're part of our great Cable Street anti-fascist movement, the Rest Is History Club, then you can listen to Tom
我不知道我刚才想说什么。我曾一度考虑开始一个非常冒险的类比。不，别那样做。然后我想，不，我不会。如果你是我们伟大的缆车街反法西斯运动——《历史的余味》俱乐部的一员，那么你可以听汤姆
talking about the Mitfords. It's going to be such fun. He just wants, you're just doing it for that impersonation, aren't you? Tragic. But also I think you have
谈论米特福德家族。那会非常有趣的。他只是想，你只是为了那个模仿才这么做的，对吧？真可悲。但我也认为你
a long established tendresse for kind of... Very, very posh women. Yeah. Horsey women. They're not horsey. Are they not horsey? I bet they ride,
对那种……非常、非常时髦的女性有一种长期存在的爱慕。是的。骑马的女性。她们不是骑马的。她们不是吗？我敢打赌她们会骑马，
don't they? Yeah, of course they ride, but they're not, they're not... Well, we will discuss that. Okay. Well, so, if you're not a? Yeah, of course they ride, but they're not, well, we will discuss. Okay. Well, so if you're not a member of the Restless History Club, if you're not joining us on the barricades at Cable Street,
对吧？是的，当然她们会骑马，但她们不是……好吧，我们会讨论那个。好吧，所以，如果你不是？是的，当然她们会骑马，但她们不是……好吧，我们会讨论。好吧，所以如果你不是《历史的余味》俱乐部的成员，如果你没有加入我们在缆车街的街垒，
if you are off in your suburban semi-detached house listening to Stanley Bouldin on the wireless, we will be back for you on Thursday with the final, the crowning moment, not just in this series, but as far as Tom Holland is concerned, in his entire professional career as he talks us through the story of the Mitfords. The women who loved Hitler.
如果你在郊区的半独立式住宅里听着斯坦利·鲍德温的无线电广播，我们将在周四回来，为你带来最后一集，这是不仅在这个系列中，而且就汤姆·霍兰而言，在他整个职业生涯中的巅峰时刻，他将为我们讲述米特福德家族的故事。那些爱上希特勒的女性。
What are you going to call it? The girl who stalked Hitler. I mean, you know, the headlines write themselves. Okay, very good. We'll see you next time. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman
你打算叫它什么？那个跟踪希特勒的女孩。我的意思是，你知道，标题自己就出来了。好的，非常好。下次见。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，
and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain
我们共同主持《娱乐的余味》，这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开
on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to there therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。